[Aplausos]
[Música]
porque num momento de crise tão grande a
gente se bate com uma notícia desse tipo
que é vai ser investido 1 bilhão e meio
no acelerador de partículas no brasil
a gente fica com a curiosidade de quem
muito dinheiro nesse momento para se
investir nisso que é que isso tem de
diferente porque isso a informação que a
gente obtém a partir desse investimento
o que a gente obtém a partir disso é que
tipo de luz a luz ela tem várias formas
a gente na área ciência chama isso de
radiação
certo a luz que tem a música está
incidindo sobre mim aqui que está na
faixa de 1 da luz visível
tá certo que esse pedaço marcado existe
a luz do seu celular
é um tipo de luz que tipo de radiação
eletromagnética existe um raio x
quando você faz o exame é um tipo de luz
é uma radiação existe em infravermelho
que é o controle existe o controle
remoto esse aqui por acaso
então existe vários tipos de radiação e
essa luz que sai determinado acelerador
ela tem um conjunto de características
particulares que nos fornece é é um
ferramental para análise de vários claro
os tipos de ciência ea gente pode atuar
em quase todos os campos da ciência com
esse com essa luz certa é essa porque
ela tão cara porque eles têm que
investir um bilhão e meio para produzir
essa luz
então o que acontece
essa luta é produzida a partir de uma
corrente elétrica como tem na nossa casa
certo só o início ela tem uma corrente
elétrica e essa corrente elétrica é
injetada em um sistema antes produzir
essa luz que tem uma quantidade imensa
uma corrente altíssima quando ela é
injetada no sistema ela precisa ser
acelerada esses elétrons que estão ali
na corrente precisam ser acelerados até
vírgula nove por cento da velocidade da
luz
tá quando a gente coloca nesse primeiro
acelerador e leva ele é 99,9 por cento a
gostar da luz
ela já está no um patamar suficiente
para que o injete ela no anel principal
tá e nesse anel principal a gente produz
o que é chamada radiação síncrotron ou
seja cada vez que é se fechou ele é
curvado no ímã você tem quando os
elétrons eles são curvados e mudam a
direção você produz uma radiação que é a
chamada radiação síncrotron e o que essa
radiação síncrotron em lobby a parte
daquele espectro mostrado e
principalmente saem do duque
infravermelho até os raios x é muito
parecido com raio x que são os que a
gente faça exame e tudo mais
e aí quando você cria um laboratório
desse tipo você produz essa luz
ela é produzida ao longo de uma de uma
estrutura é circular muito
aproximadamente circular e aí a gente
tem um bom com o laboratório em que cada
ponto desses amarelo que vocês estão
vendo são estações experimentais em que
vai ser dedicado por um determinado
estudo de determinado a mostra então eu
vou poder estudar em cada ponto de se
cada estação dessa é um estação que a
gente vai estudar o material biológico é
biodiesel todo tipo fármacos vários
vários vários materiais diferentes e eu
vou começar dando alguns exemplos que a
gente pode fazer sequer um trabalho é a
gente sabe quem teve é não é bom né mas
quem teve um caso de câncer na família
nós sabemos que é uma dança bem
complicada
só que ao longo de muitos anos vem se
desenvolver um tratamento para isso
então em 2011 a gente pode ver já já se
usava radiação síncrotron pra fazer
diagnóstico e tratar câncer
ou seja isso não é uma novidade o nosso
primeiro laboratório síncrotron ele vem
de 1997 ele a operando até hoje
um conjunto de de estudos feitos com
isso
só que depois que a gente trata o câncer
o que acontece as pessoas ganharam
depois de um tratamento bem-sucedido
ganhar uma sobrevida que antigamente era
de 5 a 10 anos
elas ganharam uma sobrevida que vai de
20 30 anos o que acontece
efeitos do tratamento do câncer
quais são os tratamentos convencionais
que nós conhecemos a radioterapia ea
quimioterapia
mas será que para tratar esse câncer nós
não temos efeitos secundários que
acontecem temos e é isso parte do
trabalho que eu desenvolvo é da
universidade do estado do rio
o que a gente faz que essa técnica nos
permite é visualizar que eu tô vendo
aqui é é um mapa é uma pinha que a gente
cria
depois que a gente faz o tratamento do
câncer isso aqui são estudos realizados
em ratos para que primeiro precisa
testar os ratinhos agente induz o câncer
depois que a gente tinha 21 cães a gente
trata o câncer nele e sacrifica o câncer
foi destruído e aí eu preciso estudar
tecidos que sofreram esses efeitos
então esse estudo aqui particularmente é
uma simulação de câncer de mama e que
nós tiramos vários tecidos tecido
decoração fazemos estudos também que
retiramos tecido de fêmur costelas para
ver os efeitos secundários ou da
radioterapia ou de quimioterapia que os
cinco outros nos permite visualizar é
coisas desse tipo que eu consigo
visualizar como se fosse um mapa que é
40 micrômetro qq micrômetro micrômetro é
a milionésima parte do metro
eu consigo fazer uma visualização no
tecido 40 por 40 micrômetros que eu
consigo saber exatamente a distribuição
dos elementos químicos dentro desse
tecido e e cada elemento químico está
relacionado com um tipo de f futuro a
patologia que porque o paciente pode ter
no caso a gente faz o rato e depois de
ser modelado por um paciente certo
outro tipo de estudo porque que nós
realizamos em colaboração com a
medicina é fazer tipo um tipo de estudo
que a gente consegue visualizar dentro
da estrutura de um cálculo renal
esse é um cálculo renal que eu faço uma
micro tomografia parecido uma tomografia
que nós fazemos no próprio exame médico
então nós conseguimos visualizar todas
as estruturas internas diferentes
densidades dentro de um cálculo renal
podendo auxiliar é futuramente médicos
no desenvolvimento de meditar técnicas
para tratar esse material essa mostra
ela foi retirada de um paciente eu faço
um estudo é em vitro que é fora do
paciente e que posteriormente podemos
fazer esse estudo em vivo certo fazer
diretamente é no paciente
então eu fiz uma eu estudei uma técnica
que foi a florescência de raio x ea
micro tomografia e raio x agente pode
combinar essas técnicas combinadas
técnicos nós conseguimos estudar dentro
do do osso esse é um outro de fêmur eu
consigo estudar a diferença de um tecido
saudável para um tecido que foi tratado
com com quimioterapia
olha como aumenta a curiosidade dele tá
certo além disso com isso com a
tomografia micro tomografia
além disso eu consigo visualizar como os
elementos químicos se distribuem em
torno do osso olha só como eu tinha uma
determinada quantidade de cálcio aqui e
depois de tratado a uma redução de caos
quanto mais roxo e azul e mais cálcio
tem e aí a gente consegue ver numa numa
escala em que equipamentos convencionais
não nos permitem certo então é só isso
tem mais coisas a gente consegue atuar
em em áreas que são até mais complexas
de visualização por exemplo quando você
produz um fármaco é esse fármaco ele tem
a finalidade de tratar uma doença não
tão recente muitos estudos mostraram que
o fármaco chaco são moléculas complexas
desse tipo
algumas pequenas alterações não fármaco
pode fazer esse fármaco ficar inativo ou
seja você toma o remédio você deve o
remédio e ele não gera um efeito ou pior
ele pode gerar um efeito contrário mas o
que é que nesse forma como é que eu vou
entender o que nesse fármaco gera essa
diferença
quero que se reparem só conseguem
reparar que aqui a posição desses dois
aqui tá diferente da posição desde que
se consegue livrar certo é isso
se eu não souber exatamente o está
localizado os átomos dentro da molécula
esse fármaco pode gerar um efeito
inverso e ao invés de tratar a doença
ele pode piorar a doença
então a radiação síncrotron ela vem
sendo desenvolvida ela vem sendo
trabalhada há muito tempo há muito tempo
no mundo todo então nós temos diversas
aplicações são aplicações é que vão da
medicina a nanotecnologia a é
desenvolvimento de novos materiais
desenvolvimento de todo todo tipo de
material que a gente possa imaginar
certo e onde nós estamos news onde que
hoje o brasil tá nessa posição temos um
equipamento já porque vamos investir
dinheiro em outro equipamento
a gente está investindo esse dinheiro
pra chegar no patamar de um equipamento
que vai estar entre os melhores
equipamentos do mundo certo vamos
competir diretamente com a europa em
termos de tecnologia desde 2003 foi
pensada a idéia desse laboratório em
torno de 2007 2008 começou a desenvolver
seriamente a idéia de construir e foi
aprovado em torno de 2008 e 2009 e hoje
nós estamos nessa foto é recente dele
estamos com 70% no laboratório pronto e
ele vai ter a capacidade como de afirmou
o diretor de visualizar a estrutura
antes nós não poderíamos não podíamos
então nós tínhamos que fazer o que no
brasil muitas vezes utilizar
laboratórios europeus
agora nossa intenção estamos no patamar
que vem sendo produzido há dez anos que
as pessoas venham até o brasil utilizar
o nosso equipamento porque nós vamos
está no topo ou muito próximo do topo da
ciência então na verdade a gente não tem
gasto um sistema que está em crise
a única forma da gente é é em melhorar é
investir em ciência e tecnologia porque
é assim que nós vamos inventar novos
materiais novos equipamentos e tratar
doenças e cobrir toda essa gama então é
a mensagem que em dez anos não tínhamos
estávamos numa margem e hoje estamos no
que muito próximo do topo da tecnologia
então pra gente é concluir a ideia 1
quando você está em crise em vista
tecnologia é a única forma da gente
superar a crise e que cada vez mais está
no no topo do que seria um 11 o ideal da
ciência tá bom
obrigado gente
[Aplausos]